from simple celebrations to the
deployment of troops in Afghanistan the
United States has been one of Germany's
closest partners for decades other
European nations are also strong allies
further afield Germany has close
relations with many countries like the
global powerhouse China but who will be
Germany's most important partner in the
future the EU our neighbouring countries
are most important or suttin did
Invictus I'd say the most important ally
is the u.s. because it's the leading
economic power and a/v tossed Martha's
butta song she did say China because
it's bigger and also more flexible fixed
eva is thirty-six percent of Germans say
China will be Germany's most important
partner in ten years time the u.s. is
second with twenty percent and France
comes in third with fourteen percent in
the point of view of military and
political security I think the US will
continue to be Germany's most important
partner in terms of NATO but from an
economic perspective we have to look
towards Asia India China and so on she
know insalata Russa treadmills president
obama holds not only center stage in
Berlin's wax museum he's also seen by a
majority here as a very real Ally to
Germany
you